[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà suivi
le championnat local ne foutent de
poitiers sinon j'aimerais vous montrer
quelques statistiques alors j'aimerais
attirer votre attention sur la première
équipe
l'équipe des trois cités et si comme moi
vous n'êtes pas un grand footeux je vous
détailler un petit peu ses stats alors
la colonne ptsc nombre de points 15
la conne j c'est le nombre de matches
joués 5 et la colonne j'ai c'est le
nombre de matches gagnés 5
on en déduit que chaque match gagné
donne trois points la colonne nc le
nombre de matches nuls 0 la colonne p
c'est le nombre de matches perdus 0
l'akron bpc nombre de buts marqués 29 et
laplane bcc nombre de buts pris 0 ce qui
fait un différentiel de 29 points ses
stats assez impressionnante 1
et si je vous disais que cette équipe
en début d'année elle a changé sa
composition
je vais vous raconter son histoire je
m'appelle jérémy j'ai 23 ans je suis
étudiant en géographie un jour d'automne
2010 est un jour où le froid s'immiscer
dans les rues de poitiers
j'étais à la bibliothèque et je reçois
un sms d'une amie lena qui me dit je
suis à paris avec achille il rentre ce
soir à poitiers il n'y a pas d'endroit
pour dormir
est ce que tu veux bien les bergers
achille c'est un jeune camerounais
exilés c'est un mineur isolé qui a
émigré en france et qui se trouvaient à
ce moment-là au consulat pour faire des
démarches administratives
alors je demande à mes colocs
on accepte et deux jours plus tard h il
arrive chez moi
je me souviens du premier repas le
sentiment que j'ai ressenti lors du
premier repas je n'étais pas
partiellement anxieux par rapport à
l'hébergement parce que depuis quelques
temps moi et d'autres amis comme l'ena
on s'était engagé auprès des mineurs
isolés qui ont immigré en france à
poitiers et on en fréquentait des jeunes
on les connaissait
moi je connaissais un petit peu certains
points de leur parcours et je savais que
c'était compliqué c'était un parcours
difficile et donc le sentiment que
j'entendais c'était de la gêne de la
gêne pour savoir comment trouver les
mots pour faire en sorte que h ils se
sentent bien chez moi qu'il considère
mon appartement comme un endroit
ressources un abri un chez lui
cet hébergement au début il devait durer
quelques jours
il a finalement duré quatre mois parce
que durant cette période il ya eu une
vague de jeunes de mineurs isolés qui
était à la rue à poitiers et durant
cette période je me suis rapproché de
différentes personnes qui comme moi
étaient sensibles à ces questions et on
réfléchissait à une solution de manière
individuelle ou collective à ce problème
je pense notamment à l'association mine
de rien mine de rien c'est le nom de
l'association qui proposait un
accompagnement auprès de ces mineurs
isolés ces jeunes et notamment qui
essaient de leur trouver des familles
d'accueil
mais durant cette période là il n'y
avait pas assez de familles d'accueil
pour héberger tous tous ces jeunes qui
étaient à la rue et donc c'était pour
moi une nécessité d'héberger quelqu'un
quatre mois plus tard h ils avaient été
reconnus mineurs par l'administration
et donc il avait quitté mon appartement
il avait été prise en charge et je
croise un autre groupe d'amis dont je
m'étais rapproché durant cette période
alors eux ils organisaient une collecte
alimentaire hebdomadaire pour pour ces
jeunes et ce jour-là il récupérer de la
nourriture un vendu dans un magasin
toujours pour pour eux et leur demander
une nouvelle et ils me disent bas là on
est avec une quinzaine de jeunes et on
va investir un bâtiment tu peux venir
avec nous est dit et moi ça me tentait
bien surtout quand on voit le bâtiment
800 m² de quoi aménager plusieurs pièces
plusieurs chambres toutes équipées pour
y vivre en plein centre de poitiers et
personne n'en faisait rien depuis une
dizaine d'années de ce bâtiment
le seul problème c'est que ce bâtiment
son propriétaire c'était l'état
alors avant d'expliquer un petit peu
l'expérience qu'on a vécu dur dans ce
bâtiment
il faut que je revienne sur pourquoi ces
jeunes il était à la rue la france a
signé la convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant qui l'obligent à
mettre à l'abri les mineurs qui sont en
danger
et ces jeunes on les appelle des mineurs
isolés
c'est à dire qu'ils sont arrivés en
france 100 par an ce qui les met de fait
en danger l'administration qui est censé
les prendre en charge ces le département
et le problème c'est que ces jeunes en
soit ils n'ont pas la capacité de
prouver leur minorité auprès du
département soit plus souvent et plus
insidieusement l'administration met tout
en oeuvre pour ne pas accepter les
preuves de reconnaissance de minorité
ces jeunes dans le jargon des gens qui
sommes sensibles à ces questions
on les appelle des majeurs niger parce
que donc ils sont mineurs mais dans
l'incapacité de prouver ce statut et ils
ne sont pas majeurs donc ils ne peuvent
pas bénéficier de l'aide mise en place
pour les majeurs ils sont donc un flou
juridique total totalement esseulé en
danger
et donc nous quand on a investi ce
bâtiment on avait à coeur de pallier à
cette carence de prise en charge
c'est à dire que on leur fournissait un
toit de la nourriture parce qu'on avait
continué à mettre en place les plans de
récup de nourriture et on faisait
marcher la solidarité de nos amis un axe
à l'hygiène à l'accès aux habits de quoi
dormir pour les quelques jeunes pour
qu'ils poitiers n'était pas la
destination mais une étape dans un
parcours ils pouvaient s'y poser
quelques jours ci repose et déstresser
reprendre des forces avant de continuer
alors parcours et puis on habitait avec
eux pour les accompagner dans leurs
démarches juridiques administratives
dans leur accès aux soins mais on avait
autre chose varela êtes on voulait pas
faire que ça on voulait faire en sorte
que ce bâtiment soit un endroit dans
lequel ils pouvaient commencer leur vie
à poitiers
certains de ces jeunes ont souscrit à
des licences de boxe d'autres à des
licences de foot
j'imagine que vous deviner dans quel
club il se sont inscrits et j'ai
vraiment beaucoup de souvenirs dans ce
bâtiment
je pense notamment parmi d'autres des
des souvenirs qui faisait faire une
ambiance de grande colloque non non non
familial les soirées passées à cuisiner
tous ensemble en écoutant de la musique
pour préparer les barbecues ou les
soirées apéro avec les copains où les
voisins
j'ai par exemple appris à cuisiner le
hand volley le hand ball et c'est un
plat camerounais à base de feuilles
bouillie à sa mère qui ressemblent à des
épinards et une sauce épicée à base
d'arachide
c'est très bon
mais j'ai d'autres souvenirs par exemple
les soirées passées à jeux de société ou
les tournois absolument interminable de
fifa qui certaines s'éterniser jusqu'à
tard dans la nuit
c'est vraiment très très chouette je
change un petit peu de sujets je vais
vous raconter une blague
j'ai un manguier un mot gay l'arbre de
la mangue forcément gay tout le monde
peut monter dessus sauf moi qui suis-je
le dos le dos bon c'est de l'humour
camerounais alors moi non plus j'ai pas
vraiment compris encore mais cette
blague on me l'a raconté lors d'une
soirée absolument magique
c'était une soirée passée au coin du feu
à regarder les étoiles et à se raconter
des devinettes des blagues qu'on a
passée à l'île d'oléron
parce que comme dans toute famille on
est parti quelques jours à l'île
d'oléron ensemble
mais des souvenirs dans ce bâtiment j'en
ai j'en ai d'autres des plus tribu aussi
par exemple avant de monter à l'étagé on
a enlevé ses chaussures et le ménage se
répartissaient de manière hebdomadaire
selon un planning en fonction des
chambres en fait on a réussi à mettre
cette ambiance familiale
très vite tout le monde a commencé à
faire référence à ce bâtiment comme
étant la maison j'habitais à la maison
est bien à la maison ce soir on cuisine
ensemble cette maison c'était leur
maison et on se sentait bien
ça fait un petit peu bizarre de repenser
à ce souvenir très fort parce que
directement après ses souvenirs le
souvenir que j'ai à près de la maison
c'est le 8 octobre 2018 j'étais devant
la porte de la maison il y avait en face
de moi une rangée de gendarmes mobiles
avec le casque la cuirasse la matraque
le bouclier et là j'entends première
sommation avant dispersion et je sens
les muscles de mon corps se contracter
et c'est pareil pour tout le groupe qui
m'accompagnait qui était devant la porte
de cette maison deuxième sommation hélas
la rangée de gendarmes se met en branle
s'approche de nous nous pousse avec
leurs boucliers
on n'est plus devant la porte et très
vite la porte et exploser tout s'est
brutalement arrêtée et eux avant de
rentrer ils ont pas enlever leurs
chaussures
alors évidemment cette expulsion on s'y
attendait deux semaines avant on avait
reçu la notification d'expulsion et même
si vous avez ça nous avait mis un choc
dans une certaine mesure les deux
semaines qui avaient suivi avaient mis
un petit peu de baume au coeur
lorsqu'on s'était rendu compte de
l'ampleur de la mobilisation citoyenne
poitevine contre cette expulsion et
mobilisation qui n'était pas composé que
d'amis ce qui veut dire que les
habitants de poitiers étaient comme nous
sensible à ces questions mais je pense
que je me suis andrée toute ma vie de
cette matinée la veille on avait reçu
une information que l'expulsion serait
pour le lendemain
l'expulsion armée et donc le lendemain
comme tous les matins je me suis levé à
5 heures pour arriver devant la porte de
la maison avant les forces de l'ordre et
ce matin là on étaient une soixantaine à
avoir fait pareil et donc on attend
en prenant le petit déjeuner avait
récupéré du mois ce lit quelques jours
plus tôt on attend une heure on attend
de 2 heures rien on commence à se dire
que l'expulsion elle serait pas pour
aujourd'hui
elle serait pour le lendemain on peut
être plus tard on avait de l'espoir
certains qui comme moi c'était lever
tous les matins à 5 heures et était un
petit peu épuisés sont rentrés pour se
reposer et moi à 8 heures il a été
chercher un café en revenant j'apprends
que il y à une quinzaine de camionnettes
de forces de l'ordre vers poitiers sud
et là tout s'est brutalement accélérée
vingt minutes plus tard
la rue a été bouclée et est ce que vous
vous vous rendez compte qu'ils ont
mobilisé une centaine de forces de
l'ordre pour dégager de chez eux
une quinzaine de jeunes
qu'ils n'avaient pas d'autre endroit où
aller
je n'avais pas d'autre endroit où aller
lorsque chacun il ya des jeunes est
sorti de la maison avec dans ses cadeaux
quelques affaires il avait un papier sur
lequel il a marqué une proposition de
relogement de deux nuits dans un hôtel
alors je sais pas si je peux tirer une
conclusion de cette expérience
on s'est confronté à trop de murs
institutionnels évidemment c'est
confronte à moins de mu institutionnel
que eux que les gars c'est pas
comparable
mais peut-être que pour terminer ce
témoignage je peux être trois bonnes
nouvelles la première des bonnes
nouvelles c'est que grâce à un certain
soutien politique
on a une nouvelle maison et 7 6 on n'a
même pas eu besoin de l'investir
illégalement cette maison elle à cette
place c'est à dire qu'on peut héberger
la moitié du groupe qui était dans la
maison à l'origine les autres on les
héberge chez nous c'est pas l'idéal mais
c'est mieux que rien surtout que ça ne
laisse pas une marge de manoeuvre pour
les prochains gamin qui mon arrivée à
poitiers parce que on sait qu'ils
continuent d'arriver à potier la
deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est que sur
les quinze gars qu'on accompagne on a
réussi à en faire scolariser un tiers un
tiers c'est pareil c'est pas tout groupe
nous on aimerait que ce soit ou groupe
mais c'est pas nous qui décidons
et ça fait quand même plaisir de les
voir se lever tous les matins avec l'
envie d'apprendre et de se former
moi j'ai commencé les deux devoirs bon
malheureusement on ne demande que de
l'aide en anglais et en maths et moi je
rêverais de faire de l'histoire géo même
pas toujours tout à voir ce qu'on veut
dans la vie
enfin la dernière bonne nouvelle c'est
que au vu de ce que je vous ai dit en
début de prise de parole est quand même
peu de chances pour que l'équipe u17 des
trois cités ne finisse pas très haut
dans le classement à la fin de la fin de
l'année à la fin du championnat et donc
moi ça me paraît évident que à la fin de
l'année ils vont finir très haut dans le
classement voire premier et à ce moment
là c'est sûr c'est sûr on fera une
grande fête tous ensemble pour fêter
cette victoire sera super on cuisinera
on écoute la musique jusqu'à pas d'heure
on sera tous ensemble on sera bien enfin
on sera tous ensemble il ya un an
que je peux pas vous promettre c'est que
dans six mois
aucun de ces gamins ne se fera expulser
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]